[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
happy Tuesday everyone I'm the queen of
mid-morning Dana Perino filling in for
the king of late night Greg Gutfeld
who's out recovering from being Greg
Gutfeld but I've come a long way since
my days as a humble prison guard
yes
[Music]
you might not have known that so tonight
I'd like to address all the moms and
dads out there or anyone who hopes to be
one someday so your children and Percy
they're counting on you
isn't he I mean he's so cute American
kids are in real trouble and I'm not
just talking about Hunter Biden
and it's something parents need to deal
with ASAP and it's not that they're
staying up late to watch the Gutfeld
show although that could stunt their
growth look at Greg a lot of people
don't realize he was 6'3 when he started
this show
but it's our schools American schools
are failing us they're failing our kids
our families and our nation in a recent
interview on my show America's Newsroom
that's weekdays at nine to ten eleven
I'm shortchanged myself an hour former
Secretary of State Condoleezza Rice
whose Own Story personifies what good
education can do called it a national
humiliation and for once she wasn't
talking about kill me's haircut
what she meant was that if we keep going
as we are the Great American experiment
could fail historically America's
education system has been one of The
Shining lights of our country for over
150 years people would crawl over glass
to get their kids into American schools
and it continues except today they're
crawling through the gaps in the border
wall
so is that still the case let's look at
the national report card reading and
math are down for 8th graders four and
nine percent respectively the numbers
for history and science they are just as
bad add that to Chronic absenteeism
which is defined as missing 10 percent
of school or more in Baltimore for
example chronic absenteeism was at 23
percent in 2016. 36 in 2020 last year it
was 58
58 percent are as Baltimore teachers
call it almost half
58 I mean Harold Ford has a better
attendance record than that
same with Joe Biden and everyone's
noticed it
[Music]
okay
[Applause]
[Music]
and so as the system deteriorates the
Dems do what they do best they print
money it's like a bootleg Monopoly game
now when you pass go and collect 200
bucks it's only worth 150.
they're now actually demanding free
community college so free college when
kids aren't even showing up for grammar
school and then after Community College
we're supposed to pay the student loans
of all these kids who majored in
advanced activism they're the ones
blocking workers on roads ordering 18
lattes twice a day and then they
complain they can't make a decent wage
in today's job market so parents I'm
talking to you now this has to stop we
can't afford it monetarily and
competitively how are our kids going to
compete with a rising China and India in
the future and please don't say by
sitting next to them while taking a test
how is the American experiment going to
compete with a militaristic and unstable
Russia right here on our own doorstep in
Latin America these hostile nations are
making tremendous inroads they're coming
folks and kids who are told there's 55
genders but can't name the 50 states
that's not going to cut it
so what should we do first stop the
bleeding get your kids Behind into that
school and I'm sorry for the strong
language
get her homework done and if that school
is not teaching what your child needs
demand it you know run for a local
school board demand standards the left
can't keep substituting wokism and
lowered standards for progress and also
demand school choice there are school
choice programs sweeping the nation the
American people will do what they can to
educate their children but they need
help and Biden isn't giving it remember
he once said that this is the smartest
person he knows
but schools that's a local issue if we
fight we can do this without Washington
without Dr Jill and her buddy Randy
miss the Multicultural multi-ethnic
democracy we need why are they making
this much money instead of plowing it
into lowering gas prices that is not
right that is not fair and that is what
we are fighting as well
and on the right you can't just say
abolish the Department of Education and
then get into office and realize that's
not going to happen and then throw up
your hands and blame everything on the
teachers union as bad as they are
dependence Independence they don't want
the Department of Education abolished
they want education to work better and
without Independence Republicans can't
win so parents it's time to get tough
this may literally be the most important
issue for our nation's future and like
my ex-husband Eminem once said success
is our only option
[Applause]
so let's welcome tonight's guests like a
toddler in church he'll leave you
rolling in the aisles comedian Jeff die
he's our favorite VP after the oil
producer that killed all those seagulls
co-founder of a base politics Brad
Palumbo
she's like Taco Bell she's great at
first but has the potential to kill you
in your sleep boxes contributor cat Tim
and he retired from the ring but he'll
still wrestle anyone that steals his
bling New York Times best-selling author
comedian at former NWA world champion
Cyrus can I start with you it's your
show
um
does that get bleeped just kidding um
Tyrus you're a dad yes you care about
education you're a teacher yes what I
mean are we right here you are a
thousand percent right and unfortunately
it's our fault we we stopped paying
attention to the kids we're we everyone
wants to blame the kids it's the tablets
it's the the technology they're not
focused they're doing that but the
parents are doing that like who allows
the children to do these things we used
to be partners with our teachers and and
yes we see on the media the extreme
version of a lot of the school teachers
and used to be like one or two in every
school there was that one teacher or
maybe two now you define the normal
teacher they're the weird ones the one
that wears the bow tie and wants to
teach science is the one that everyone's
going I don't know about that guy so we
have to in some days and parents we have
to start sacrificing 50 of my kids that
means half right they're they're they're
home school and the other two were in
private school so there's no more public
school for for my kids and there's a lot
of sacrifices but we need to start
looking at getting back to the
communities getting together with our
neighbors maybe we homeschool our
neighborhood and parents all work
together and take turns to get back to
math English History accurate you know
best that covers those things algebra is
is not a gender it's math so we need to
get back to those things and it's going
to take because if the kids aren't there
they can't make their money they can't
get their subsidies so maybe we just
don't do business with them anymore and
we start doing a Grassroots education
system Americans can do it we just need
to pull together bring Grandma's back
who do you think is to blame for this
downfall I don't know who to blame
everyone everyone's blaming these kids
like Tyler said like oh they're not
showing up for school in over 56 percent
of the students aren't showing up for
school in Baltimore it's like yeah have
you seen schools lately the dude
teachers are showing up with prosthetic
boobs the women teachers are talking
about uh teaching them sex stuff
everything's gay everything white is
racist I'm commend to these kids for not
showing up
smart kids my kids wait that they might
have potential a brad at the recent
Republican debate just last week so many
of the candidates said they would just
eliminate the Department of Education
but a lot of people have said that for a
long time and then they get there and
like realize that that's not going to
happen so that can't be the only
solution no I mean I support that in
theory too but you've got to have more
practical Solutions and I'm really glad
you brought up school choice because
that's the most obvious one we can't
just keep throwing money at the system I
mean we spend fifteen thousand dollars
per student it's 30 more than other
developed countries clearly just
shoveling more money which is what
Democrats always say is not going to fix
our education crisis but actually giving
Parents Choice like maybe the Money
Follows the student and goes to the
school that best fits that kid's needs
not just the public school by default
maybe it's a public school but maybe
it's a private school maybe it's a
charter school maybe it's tyrus's house
maybe maybe it's his neighborhood
stories I can fit at least 100 in there
and you could take them over to see all
the animals listen back in the day in a
little house with Prairie it was like
there was like 50 kids stuck in a box
with one teacher yeah and no one lifted
their head up they all did the work so
it can be done cat Brad has a good point
there's actually it's not that we're not
spending enough money right on kids or
maybe we maybe we are but we're spending
it wrong but the in some of these school
districts the more money that you give
them the scores are still as bad
yeah absolutely and I think that school
choice I'm glad you brought that up I'm
glad we talked about that because
they're really the problem with looking
for a solution to this is there's no
one-size-fits-all solution because I
don't have kids but from my
understanding they are people
so at times so and people are different
so different think what might work for
one kid might not work for another kid
so we really have to acknowledge that
reality and also we can't be surprised
because even this is you know better
than it was a few years ago when school
was illegal
in the pandemic I mean the education was
no so I mean that's that's truly insane
and I think that there there's been all
this learning loss that we kind of found
out happened and then kind of just went
man that's a bummer and right and then
nothing happened to try to address that
that was just having kids stay at home
is going to impact them it has impacted
them so what are we going to do to try
to solve that should at least kind of
try to do some homework and sure
spelling and math is down but according
to my measurements podcast listening is
up 98 points only fans is up 99 points
and kids transitioning is up 100 I mean
that's like that's higher than three
years that's nearly complete yeah so
what's everyone paranoid about this fine
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else